senator Joni Ernst is calling herself a
survivor and speaking out for the first
time about being sexually assaulted in
college
the Iowa Republicans hold Bloomberg News
yesterday she was raped by someone she
knew while attending Iowa State
University Ernst also opened up about
unrelated alleged physical abuse in her
marriage the 48 year-old became
emotional during a meeting last night
with constituents she talked about her
claim revealed in divorce papers that
her then husband Gail Ernst physically
assaulted her and had an affair what I
want to remind everybody is that I'm
still the same person as it was a week
ago
the only difference is they're you know
more about me now oh thank you Gail
learns to also accuse the senator of
having an affair both deny infidelity
accusations Gail Ernst has not responded
to our request for comment on the
alleged physical abuse you know my heart
goes out to Senator Ernst you can see
that the pain that she is feeling from
abuse she said she did want to talk
about this but in the era of me too
everybody comes to their story at a
different time you can still see it's
very painful for her a painful